- Happy belated birthday, a few weeks ago
you had a huge birthday.
It's a big birthday.
- You know Kelly, I
don't count them anymore.
- You don't?
- No, I mean, I feel blessed
to have another day of life
for sure, but-
- That's why I do count them.
Not everybody gets them.
- We're not gonna talk numbers.
- Oh, no you don't have to.
But not everybody gets
you know, that many years.
So it is a blessing.
- It is true.
- Yeah, and it's good to celebrate.
I'm opposite, I don't care about age.
I don't really care.
- Age is a funny thing.
You know, what I find is that, my God
as I've gotten older, I
just get more sensitive.
Like-
- Oh yeah.
- I'll watch watch your
show, your other show.
I'll watch you on "The Voice"
and I'll watch a young singer
who aspires to be a
superstar like you and-
- [Kelly] Oh, the stories get you?
- And the stories, for sure, yeah,
but the song itself will move me to tears.
And my son who's 17 and kind of tough,
looks over at me and goes-
- [Kelly] What are you doing?
- Why are you crying?
Like, why are you crying?
I said, buddy, "I cry
at coffee commercials".
Like, I don't know why I'm crying.
- Yeah.
- As I've gotten older,
I don't know what's going on with me.
But I don't know, maybe it's-
- [Kelly] That's a man thing, I feel like-
- Facing mortality now,
I don't know what it is.
- I don't know.
But I also feel like, men I think you've-
I think you've, especially my generation,
your generation like, they were taught
they weren't allowed to be emotional.
You were supposed to be strong
or whatever, like growing up.
And I feel like, I don't know
over the course of the time,
I think you should go
on, you're just like,
"Whatever, it's touching.
I'm gonna let it out.
I'm gonna cry."
- That's not the-
Yeah, that's not the lesson
I teach in my household.
(Kelly laughing)
You're free and welcome
to cry at any moment.
- [Kelly] I know, but we're in different-
I'm teaching my children
differently as well,
but I just meant from our generation
it was always like, I'm from the South.
Like, it was like, don't show emotion.
- Oh, of course.
- That is weak.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Whatever.